please just listen to me please
okay i'll go to little lady hit
i make mistake and then i i'll change
ji hoon ji hoon after flipping out on
devin
and telling her to go back to america he
is now asking
for another chance but the question is
will devin allow him back in
i need you to transfer me to three
thousand dollars today to prove that you
want me to be here
and to prove that you're going to step
up after all she's gone through
the answer it might surprise you
hey my 90 day fans fam it's malicia
on the latest episode of the other way
the couples came
face to face with family members who
doubt the future of their relationships
and in jihoon and devin's case a family
member who is
literally holding any potential of their
future together
in her bank account
yes devin gave jihoon an ultimatum
get the money you saved in your mom's
bank account right now
or we're done it's not necessarily about
having this money
it's about knowing he's not lying
and i need him to prove he's not lying
okay
mom agreed to go to the atm she really
is not taking this serious
at all
i'm convinced that she does not
understand what's going on
it's either that or she just doesn't
care to
her husband even told her that she's not
getting the situation
mom is still taking up for her son who
has
admitted to being wrong
[Music]
don't worry
[Music]
are you actually going to change during
this episode jihoon revealed that the
reason why
he didn't save any money for devon is
because he didn't take the relationship
seriously due to long distance
so i'm all for allowing people
space to change but at this point
words really don't mean anything it's
time to see some action
and giving devin the money it was a good
start
so i'm begging you
please forgive me trust me again
one more for child
the next day jihun stop by where devin
is staying
to have a conversation about their
future as
for the whole
budgeting issue from now on
your money needs to go into a joint
bank account my own bank account
yes with my name and your name yes
not your parent's name yeah yeah okay
my money your money within one month if
you haven't changed
i will go back to america devin says
that she's only doing this for her son
so
we just have to wait and see if jihoon
actually changes
as time will tell so one of the concerns
that i had was his other relationship
that's why we got fear about their
relationship
because his past is not good our final
must-see moment goes to binium sisters
who also voiced their concerns
about his relationship with a new
american woman
so now he bring another american
we got a fear what if this relationship
didn't work
yeah what's gonna happen to the baby are
you gonna take this baby
no i wouldn't want to do that to him
that's why
you know it's important that we figure
out the visa and everything so that if i
have to go there something he could come
with me
because i don't want him to feel like
you know i'm going and not coming back
that conversation actually ended very
well
but soon after ariella and her mom
went to go see binium where he performs
every night
and red flags were just
popping up everywhere who is this person
he's dancing with
yeah he's exciting but how long was he
his girlfriend
i don't know i'm definitely a jealous
person i think anyone who says that
they're not jealous is a liar
[Music]
let's just move on to what's coming up
next week you guys ready
it looks like jihoon is sticking to his
word so far and stepping up to the plate
david and i find a new apartment
there's so much riding on this apartment
because
my mom wants to take me and the kids
right back to america
okay let's go you know sometimes you
just have to clap
for the little ones all right my 90 day
fans fam
make sure you stick with e.t to stay
updated on all the latest news
from our guilty pleasure see you next
time
[Music]